voilà c'est un jeu qui s'appelle gagner
du temps et il va au salon de la culture
donc c'est vraiment un jeu plaisant je
vais être obligée de faire un axe aux
pectoraux excusez moi il arrivait il
fait le tour des stands comme ça il va
voir le stand des trieuses électrique
voilà
puis 10 bonjour monsieur oui bonjour
monsieur un peu des renseignements mais
le match là je vois ça l'air de bien
marcher
ça semble bien je dois y a est ce que
par hasard parce que je vois qu'ils
allaient les 6 pi 2 la vache qui sont en
action est ce que par hasard ça pourrait
marcher sur cinq dit oui à elle est
viable
tu peux écouter monsieur pas de problème
a priori je pense que points et il s'en
va il est ok d'accord il fait le tour du
filet il va avoir d'autres sens voilà le
stand et puis tout dérape à macha et
revient oui tu assez long et je vais
aller jusqu'au bout à ce qu
éventuellement c'est ça peut marcher sur
doping et le tipi dit bah écoute et
gaëtan oui ça marche aussi pis sur 5 pi
sur trois pistes ça peut marcher sur
deux pieds et dyala c'était bien il s'en
va il reviendra pas il fait le tour du
simple bon sens gêné la petite comme ça
elle va voir le il va voir le vendeur de
13 et fizi bon n'en dit pas plus
d'accord vous finirez cette bague dans
un instant on en est ou de cette blague
mais je sais plus si je suis à 3 puis on
a depuis épi ce cru est là dessus alors
bis alors alors revenir à venir en dc
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon il va nous
raconter sable a doublé